[موسيقى]
استغرق الأمر عشر سنوات أكثر من عشرة
آلاف طن من الفولاذ ومئات
الملايين من الدولارات حتى
هذه اللحظة ، كان افتتاح متحف اللوفر
أبو ظبي في نوفمبر 2017
حدثًا تاريخيًا يمثل بداية فصل جديد
ليس فقط بالنسبة إلى  متحف اللوفر وكذلك
أبو ظبي كمركز ثقافي بعد أسابيع فقط
من تجول الزوار الأوائل في
صالات العرض تحت القبة ، التقيت
مع كبير الدبلوماسيين الإماراتيين الشيخ
عبد الله بن زايد لاكتشاف كيف
يعزز المتحف الجديد تأثير الدولة المتزايد
في العالم.  أعتقد أن
افتتاح هذا المتحف كان
يومًا سيئًا للغاية بالنسبة للمتطرفين ولحسن الحظ بالنسبة
للكثيرين منا ، لقد كان يومًا رائعًا
[موسيقى]
لقد تصوره
الرئيس جاك شيراك كما أفهمه
كوسيلة لمحاربة التطرف بالفن بعد
ما كان في ذلك الوقت الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
والهجمات نظرًا لافتتاح المتحف
في وقت ساد فيه عدم استقرار إقليمي كبير ،
فإن هذه الرؤية الأصلية أصبحت
أكثر أهمية من أي وقت مضى ما لم نكن
مستعد حقًا في هذا الجزء من العالم
في معالجة أيديولوجيتهم للمتطرفين
الذين يكرهونهم ويصنعون منحوتات مثل
متحف اللوفر ، هذا المتحف لا
يختلف كثيرًا عن الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي أنعم الله على
نشأتها في بلد كان
متسامحًا كان مفتوحًا.  حديث
ولكنه أيضًا نجح في
إعطاء شعوب هذه المنطقة للبلدان
والقادة في هذه المنطقة بعض الأمل في أن
هذه هي نوع من المشاريع التي
لن تعزز فقط العلاقة بين الحكومة والحكومة
بشكل أفضل للعلاقة الشريرة
التي أعتقد أنها  دائما
أكثر أهمية